what is it they need to stay alive
water
food
certainly
but what we need most
is life itself
what do you all think you're doing why
the fighting what you think it's like
for us losing friend after friend the
face of your real enemies lure bars to
bore this world their existence must be
erased without a trace
[Music]
this is the world of ionians
the nations of kevis and agnes and their
grisly conflict stand in contrast to its
natural splendor
the people of this world live short life
spans of just 10 years
from the moment they're born fighting is
all the people of ionia's learn
[Music]
the story of xenoblade chronicles 3
focuses on six soldiers three from kevis
and three from agnes
when they come face to face during a
special mission both parties draw their
weapons but after encountering a
mysterious figure they resolve to work
together
because now kids you share a common
destiny
they'll hunt you constantly
relentlessly without rest
there's one place that might give you a
chance
sword march
our city
[Music]
ionios is host to various landscapes
all filled with surreal geography to
explore and diverse wildlife to
encounter
draw your weapon when encountering an
enemy to seamlessly enter battle
make your approach to attack
automatically
then harness powerful abilities called
arts to strive for victory
arts have a variety of effects some can
throw opponents off balance
inflict more damage based on where you
attack from
or heal allies to name a few
string together arts to activate a combo
and gain an advantage
get the enemy off balance knock them to
the ground
launch them into the air then smash them
down
stringing together successful combos is
quite satisfying
[Music]
what is that thing you've got a real
death wish
it's not over yet
i felt her thoughts
there were so many
and then they were a part of me
by joining together in battle through
interlinking two characters in your
party confused into a fiercely powerful
form known as
[Music]
without limits
use soul points and in battle to make
the ul burros even stronger
each character in your party has a class
that influences how they battle
each character takes on a specific role
during battles
attackers excel at damaging enemies
defenders block enemy attacks and draw
their aggro
and healers can restore health points to
keep you in fighting shape
each character playing in the role
effectively is a key point to battling
your class can also be changed to match
that of your allies
[Music]
and that's not all
doing the same as everyone around you
it's always the same outcome it's just
that as a mechanic you can't stop
getting moody just because something's
broken
brave residents of ionians called heroes
can lend their arms and aptitude to your
team as a seventh party member
only one hero at a time can assist on
the battlefield
but you can swap them out as you see fit
heroes also have their own unique
classes
by befriending these allies your party
members can take on these classes too
recruit more heroes for a growing
combination of classes and arts for your
party
[Music]
ioneos is host to a variety of terrains
and climates
once you start to explore you'll
encounter creatures that make no secret
of their ferocious tendencies
as well as hidden areas to discover and
more
harsh yet beautiful landscapes await you
colonies serve as the base camp for both
nations
[Music]
at rest spots found in colonies and
throughout the world you can cook using
collected materials
[Music]
craft gems to strengthen your abilities
looks good to me
and discuss information you've heard
from residents to take on new quests
[Music]
explore every corner of these fields as
you seek out new encounters
breathtaking scenery
valuable items
and ferocious monsters
enjoy the world and fulfill your
wunderlust at your own pace
[Music]
we were sworn enemies once
and yet
we all share the will to live in the now
not now we seem to be sharing a common
destiny we happy few
these soldiers will nourish me and we
can always grow plenty more
you guys
really make my sparks fly
get back to killing each other come on i
thought that was your whole razon death
trap these are our lives here
they're not some toys you could just
play with
xenoblade chronicles 3
broaden the world of xenoblade
chronicles 3 with a paid expansion pass
additional content will be released over
time
[Music]
xenoblade chronicles 3 is compatible
with amiibo figures
tap any amiibo to acquire helpful
in-game items for your adventure
tap the shulk amiibo to change a
character's sword to appear as the
monado when using noah's sword fighter
class
[Music]
you